another great piece of advice at work
for one gillespee is that before an
audition she said get to your audition
location like a half hour or 45 minutes
early read in the car listen to
classical music or something to kind of
center yourself do you have any things
that you do so that you're not rushing
around town and you walk in the door
frazzled and then the casting director
says let's always liked me being an
emotional crazy person how I am is I
didn't think that's a good thing you
know I try to always get there early and
again I'm gonna go back to this just
because it's like what makes me tick is
it's a little bit harder in the summer
but I bring my dog a lot to some
auditions and she's the one thing that I
can just I think she helps me in a way
just um just you know like just be real
and just being in that moment I mean I
mean Harper issues such a gentle so
lunch I guess she gets me to that point
where because the more calm I am the
more I guess creative place that I can
get to the more focus i am but um I can
be very hyper and sometimes when you're
hyper and everything that could be great
if feel like if the scene even was for
hyper jumpy guy but you're not focused
when that happens at least at least I'm
not and again it's I think they can
sense like if you had that hyper-guy
hyper the role was a hyper guy some
bonnie is she's she's evil she so she's
so talented like she would be able to
sense somebody that is just hyper or
somebody that's that's in a way like
acting hyper in a creative way she'd be
able to sense that and so I think um I
bring my dog a lot to some auditions and
just depending like on like where the
parking is and stuff like that you know
obviously Stern the summer I don't tell
him you know I can't bring her because
it's so hot but um there's a couple
places that I know of that um couple
casting directors is safe oh my god you
know what bring your dog in it so um you
know she's very quiet and she say
able to sit in the corner it's not a
problem but for me it's like she helps
keep me on the level the level yes she
does
you